[Musik]
meine lieben iranerinnen und iraner ich
bitte euch ich flehe euch anlass diese
treuen armen tiere nicht sterben
so fing alles an mit kondomen vor sechs
jahren fand hossein mohammadi die hündin
halb tot auf der straße
er päppelte sie wieder auf und so sieht
dann dom heute aus eine schöne gepflegte
alte hundedame er dokumentierte kondoms
rettung im internet und wurde dadurch
bekannt in iran und auf der ganzen welt
als der mann der sich in der islamischen
republik um die gepeinigten kreaturen
kümmert alles wurde immer größer und
immer professioneller vor allem nachdem
die bilder von gun dom im netz und in
einigen fernsehsendern gezeigt wurden da
haben sich viele leute bei mir gemeldet
und haben ihre hilfe angeboten
damit noch mehr hunde versorgt werden
können er sammelte spenden erweiterte
sein tierheim kaufte medikamente doch es
gab leider und unverständnis denn für
viele religiös konservative gilt der
hund als unrein als schmutzig als große
ratte mit wedelndem schwanz und die
schoßhündchen der reichen als ausdruck
westlicher dekadenz
so kursieren im internet grausame bilder
von misshandlungen und von schlimmerem
straßenhunde werden gequält werden
geprügelt im august 2009 10 kam es zu
einem skandal mit säure spritzen töteten
hundefänger im auftrag der behörden
zahllose tiere da platzte vielen der
kragen
tausende zogen vor die stadtverwaltung
in teheran kommt raus wir haben keine
säure riefen sie wir tun euch nichts der
staatsbeamte versuchte sich zu wehren
man habe die firma die für die taten
verantwortlich sei gefeuert der protest
gegen staatliche tierquälerei in iran
aber wächst von tag zu tag und so
beeilen sich heute die religiösen zu
betonen dass der koran hunde nicht
verachten man solle sie zu vermeiden
oder sich nach einer berührung sieben
mal die hände waschen quellen oder gar
töten aber dürfe man sie nicht
man kann sagen das tier rechtem islam
fast das gleiche gewicht haben wie die
menschenrechte das heißt tiere zu quälen
ist ein verbrechen sie als sport oder
zur unterhaltung zu jagen und zu
verletzen ist ebenfalls ein verbrechen
dazu gibt es schriftliche
überlieferungen und rechtliche
vorschriften davon aber spürt amir reza
im täglichen leben nichts stattdessen
erlebt er strenge regeln und schikanen
von polizei und ämtern
trotzdem will er sich einen neuen hund
kaufen auf dieser hunde zuchtfarm in
karaj wird nur reinrassiges vermittelt
an betuchte kunden aus der hauptstadt
teheran wie amir reza in einigen
bezirken sei es verboten hunde auf
öffentlichen plätzen auszuführen oder im
auto zu transportieren erzählte die
leute kümmern sich nicht mehr um diese
regeln
sie leisten widerstand sie unterstützen
die hunde nicht nur die die sie gekauft
haben
auch die hunde die auf der straße leben
die leute füttern sie ich glaube nicht
dass diese regeln noch lange bestand
haben
es wird sich ändern eines tages
amir reza steht für eine wachsende
gemeinde die sich teure hunde leisten
will und leisten kann denn die preise
sind saftig ein wollknäuel wie dieser
tibetanische mastiff welpe kostet stolze
3000 euro die hundezucht sei ein
boomendes geschäft in iran
doch die us-sanktionen machten ihnen zu
schaffen meinen die beiden firmenchefs
wegen der wirtschaftssanktionen haben
wir einige hunderassen nicht mehr
einführen können
das hat unser geschäft natürlich sehr
stark behindert aber auch der starke
anstieg des dollar kurses der hat die
kaufkraft unserer kunden extrem
verringert wenn sie wir erleben gerade
eine große kulturelle veränderung was
das thema haustierhaltung betrifft ich
zum beispiel komme aus einer religiösen
familie mein vater hätte es bis vor
einiger zeit niemals toleriert dass sich
hunde halten kaufen oder verkaufen
das hätte er nicht geduldet amir reza
entscheidet sich schließlich für den
drei monate alten cane corso welten kajo
einen italienischen hütehund kaufpreis
1000 euro er ist für mich wie gemacht so
auf jeden fall
der wird mal sehr groß und wird mich
beschützen egal was passiert
kajo wird es sicher besser gehen als den
vielen promenaden mischungen draußen auf
den straßen zurück zu hause in dem hunde
retter eine bekannte hatte ihn zu hilfe
gerufen
sie hatte diese prächtige kranke hündin
entdeckt wieder ein fall für den mann
mit dem herz für geschundene tiere
[Musik]
herr mohammadi ist der einzige den ich
kenne der sich in unserer provinz um
solche fälle kümmert der hund war hier
in der nähe
herr mohammadi kommt dann gleich vorbei
und macht seine sache sehr gut ab in die
transportbox und zu den anderen hunden
in seinem tierheim viele seiner
schützlinge vermittelt er an
hundeliebhaber in europa in den usa und
kanada
er hat eine sondergenehmigung der us
finanzbehörden ist von den
wirtschaftssanktionen ausgenommen darf
spendengelder auch aus den usa empfangen
amerika und hossein in iran vereint im
kampf für den hund mittlerweile hat die
gerettete hündin eine grundreinigung
bekommt da sie unter einer hautkrankheit
leidet und eine abgeschlagene potter hat
wird der tierarzt sie noch heute oder
morgen behandeln sie soll erst mal mit
den anderen hunden keinen kontakt haben
und keine krankheiten zu übertragen
stoisch lässt sie die vorbereitungen auf
ihr neues leben über sicher gehen und so
hat horst er ihn auch gleich einen namen
für sie aram die ruhige denn sie spürt
wohl dass die die ihr hier ins fell
wollen nur gutes im sinn haben